killing obamacare killing obamacare has
been an obsession of number one
republicans when obama was still
president remember the dozens and dozens
oh was it sixty seventy eighty attempts
to sixty one sixty one votes to repeal
obamacare in the house and number two
getting rid of obamacare has been a
priority of donald trump's since he's
become president of the united states
and what has been able to what he has
been able to do to attack obamacare are
basically two things number one trump's
tax reform plan remove that individual
mandate from the tax plan and that piece
of it I think you said Pat doesn't get
enacted until next year is it the actual
removal of the mandate it's not entirely
sure about that one yeah at some point
that that gets enabled and that will
make it so that you no longer pay a
penalty if you don't have individual
health insurance that is meant to
financially destabilize the system it's
meant to hurt Obamacare as a to create a
pretext to then get rid of it number two
Donald Trump's administration abruptly
suspended payments to Obamacare programs
and as I've talked to you about before
if you can't get rid of the law get rid
of the money that makes the law work and
the administration is doing indeed that
ten point four billion dollars in
payments to insurers were suspended
abruptly by the Trump administration the
insurers of course immediately said well
if we don't get this money through the
ACA arrangement we're just gonna
increase premiums on customers to make
up the difference and withholding these
funds is such a disaster that the
Republican chairman of the House Ways
and Means Committee Republican
congressman Kevin Brady not exactly a
moderate Republican a pretty far-right
ideologue he is now asking the Trump
administration to restart those payments
and as a reminder this guy's hugely
against Obamacare the hugely against
Obamacare and he recognizes the disaster
that this is and the House Ways and
Means Committee recognizes how much of a
disaster this is the Republicans are so
concerned about the elimination of these
payments that they are considering
legislative action to force the payments
to restart Republican president stops
the payments Republican committee leader
might pass legislation to start
back up think about how insane this is
and by the way don't think for a second
that Republicans are doing this because
of some moral responsibility that they
feel the midterms are coming that's all
it is Democrats are already starting to
talk about the rising premiums that have
been taking place and are going to
continue with these funds suspended and
Republicans know that they will suffer
if premiums continue to explode because
of this decision by Donald Trump for all
we know as soon as the midterms are over
the Republicans will go back to Trump
and say have at it you can re suspend
those payments we don't have an election
coming up but for the bottom-dwelling
Trumpets who are supposedly fiscal
conservatives they are already saying
Pat this is taxpayer money this is good
this is ten point four billion in
taxpayer money that's not being used for
Obamacare and to them I would say you
were wrong this is money collected from
insurers whose pool of customers is on
average healthier and redistributed to
the insurers who are doing a good thing
mind you insuring less healthy people
it's a redistribution meant to not
penalize insurance companies for
insuring less healthy people it's
insurance company money it's not tax
payer money yeah so unless the American
people are just by and large looking out
for the good of big insurance companies
rapists it really shouldn't bother them
that much there is such a heart
heartwarming sentiment for the corporate
health insurance industrial complex in
this country that it makes perfect sense
that people would have a special place
in their heart for these wait a sec what
what the hell am I talking about most
important overarching story here is that
for seven years the Republicans slammed
Obamacare they took 60 something votes
in the house to repeal it knowing it
would never happen they campaigned and
so did Trump on as soon as Trump is in
office it's out Obamacare is out and the
public is opposed to the repeal of
Obamacare every iteration proposed by
Republicans to repeal Obamacare would
have led to tens of millions or multiple
tens of millions I guess is what it
would I mean of people ending up without
health insurance and what they're doing
instead is there
taking these small cuts at Obamacare to
further try to sabotage it or sabotage
if you are of William Shatner's
pronunciation sabotage Obamacare from
succeeding great leadership and vision
right seven years to come up with
something everything they propose is
garbage they can't get it done and now
Republicans are going to trump and
saying please restart these payments
yeah and Republicans now own the issue
of health care right because do they
can't just gut the Affordable Care Act
and do nothing to replace it and I don't
know what they're gonna do going forward
but if this is their only strategy it's
not gonna be very good for them that's
an empirical analysis based on actual
facts and data I am not convinced that
short of exploding premiums even above
like the underlying increase in premiums
that Republican hardline voters are
actually going to say that it's
Republicans who are to blame for this
because you know what they'll say it's
Obama care if Obama hadn't put this in
place in the first place the fact that
it's not working right wouldn't matter
forget the fact that it's Republicans
who are making sure that it doesn't work
correctly really bad really bad and we
will see what impact it has on the
election but more importantly people's
lives are at stake
Republicans are playing politics with
this because they want to get reelected
in 3-4 months however long it is at this
point and people's lives actually depend
on this stuff send me your thoughts
about these atrocities that are taking
place I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
today's program brought to you in part
by Blink accom slash Pakman Linkous is a
great service that I use all the time
what they do is they take thousands of
the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink Asst
I recently checked out soccer na mcc's
by Simon Cooper we do have after all the
World Cup going on recently we also have
been talking about BS jobs and there
is a great new book PS jobs by David
Graeber
which I listen to on bling cos they're
constantly adding new books to the
platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
is comm slash Pakman if you're watching
on YouTube I'm putting a link in the
video description and after the free
trial if you like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
that's be li NK is t.com /p a que mas